while the initial appearance of this new
world is to begin with only the whole
veiled in its simplicity or the general
foundation of the whole the wealth of
previous existence is still present to
consciousness and memory consciousness
misses in the newly emerging shape its
former range and specificity of content
and even more the articulation of the
form whereby distinctions are securely
defined and standard rate in their fixed
relations without such articulation
science lacks universal intelligibility
and gives the appearance of being the
esoteric possession of a few individuals
an esoteric possession since it is yet
only present in its notion or its
inwardness of a few individuals since
its undefeated a shoe makes its
existence something singular only what
is completely determined is that once
exoteric comprehensible and capable of
being learned and appropriated by all
the intelligible form of science is the
way open and equally accessible to
everyone and consciousness as it
approaches science justly demands that
it be able to attain rational knowledge
by way of the ordinary understanding for
the understanding is thought the pure
eye as such and what is intelligible as
all is what is already familiar and
common to science and the unscientific
consciousness alike
the latter through it is having a four
to direct access to the former
there are two main things going out in
this section one of them which I already
have sort of sketched out on the board
has to do with this this contrast
between two different ways of looking at
the the new world that's developing the
new world in the old world are kind of
interfused and I don't wanna linger on
that too long because I want to say what
the second thing is the second thing is
Hegel is going to begin to lay out some
of the desiderata the criteria for what
is actually going to count as as
scientific knowledge systematically
developed and is going to introduce a
new portion of that that criterion so
far we've got that you know it has to be
systematic has to take account of itself
there's a number of different things but
this is going to be something new but
first let's look at what's actually
going on here so he talks about
consciousness as being caught between
two different polarities and I'm
actually going to begin with the second
one he begins bringing up this notion of
a wealth of previous experience and what
we're talking about there is we've been
exploring this new world you know the
metaphor the of the baby the child and
the old world that is tottering that you
can tell this is beginning to
disintegrate through this this you know
qualitative leap that's taking place
through quantitative growth why are we
still holding on to that well it still
has a great attraction for consciousness
in general if we want to think about it
in terms of society or cultures and for
individual consciousnesses this is part
of what in phenomenological terms used
later on we would call the life world or
Hegel will actually call substantial
life later on in his phenomenology
and what is so attractive about this
well there's a wealth of content as he
is he calls it a not just wealth but a
range and specificity of content so the
things that we're familiar with you know
think about for example the
transformations that are taking place
today with online education this is a
prime example when online education
first began and I would say here's the
dirty little secret about it for the
most part still today people would
transpose the categories that they
already knew they thought you could just
upload a bunch of content and you might
be changing the form slightly but really
we're wedded to the 15 week semester or
the 10 week semester of the 12 week
semester whatever it is that we're used
to and we got to do grades in a certain
way and how are we going to get around
the fact that we don't have a lot of
interaction discussion forums that will
substitute for that and discussion
forums are like face-to-face interaction
you see where this is going right people
are used to things that actually work
that they have experience with and they
may be you know they may be not working
as well as as one thinks one can tell
and so if all sorts of stories about
that but at least they have some
specificity and at least they have some
structure that we understand he talks
about form going along with content and
this is this is a do head or dyad that's
going to show up a lot in Hegelian
thought not only do we have reigned and
specificity of content we have the
articulation of form the articulate Ness
so form gives us distinctions
it helps us anchor those distinctions it
helps us differentiate things from each
other the content begets to be content
by being structured by form so we have
this in the form of the the old world
and we realize that the old world has
cracks
it's not our our conception of it isn't
fully adequate and and there may be you
know great bifurcations where we
understand the world of work this way
the world of the family this way the
world of religion this way and the
different systems don't map on to each
other but at least they have what
appears to be a sort of richness to them
by contrast the new world what's being
developed where the dialectic is going
as merely the general foundation of the
whole or as we said before the notion of
the whole and the notion in its in its
primary undeveloped state where it's
really a universal that risks being an
abstract empty universal so this is
going to bring up the issue of science
he says without the kind of articulation
that we have over here science which is
what we want over here can't really be
what it's supposed to be it's going to
lack universal intelligibility and it
gives the appearance of being the
esoteric possession of a few individuals
this is going to lead us to the second
part now so we want to think about the
nature of what Hegel has been calling
science science wants to develop itself
in a certain way who wants to unfold
itself and when a science comes on the
scene a new way of knowing a new way of
articulating things it appears to be the
esoteric possession of a few so what
does all this mean so esoteric is
opposed to exoteric esoteric means that
there's it's coming from the word for
inside exoteric would be the outside the
shell so think of something where
there's there's a story being told and
the story is actually supposed to
illustrate a greater point so there's an
exoteric meaning like take a fable right
ASA wrote all these moralizing tales
where for instance the Fox or the DOE I
will use the one about the dog the dog
is a bone in its mouth it goes along it
sees another dog you know which is
really itself in the water and it barks
at that dog and it loses the ball so
what you can say okay well that's a neat
story that's the exoteric
portion of the story what's the esoteric
inside moral well maybe keep your mouth
shut or when you've got something good
hold on to it and don't worry about who
else there is that that has something
similar there could be more than one
esoteric meaning but what Hegel is
calling science risks becoming something
merely esoteric and my E says an
esoteric possession since it's yet
present only in its notion or in its
inwardness
so insofar as we're just talking about
the beginning of a notion
the beginning of a concept of beginning
of a big R if it's esoteric it hasn't
been fully developed yet you have to you
have to be in the know in order to make
sense of it why is it the possession of
just a few individuals because he says
it's undefiled so now you might say well
what is happening its undefeated
appearance some diffuse manifestation
makes us exist in something singular
it's not happening everywhere there are
selected places so you know think for
example about some of the things that
are that are bursting on the scene at
this time you know one of the things
that people are always well I will take
two of them one of them I brought up
before another one is one that I haven't
talked much about
so think about mindfulness and how
everybody's talking about that these
days and you know if you pin them down
on it it's often kind of vague about
what exactly it means turns out it's
sort of like sort of like meditation
practices from from some Eastern
philosophies although you can find a lot
of these in western philosophies light
that is stripped away and you know
you're supposed to focus on the present
and on your sensations and not try to
bring a lot of things to the experience
really you're doing phenomenology but
you're doing phenomenology light now is
that something that everybody's doing on
a certain level you know you have to be
doing that or you can't actually be
conscious but as a movement it's it's
not something super widespread that's
why you can have gurus that you know
lead workshops about this sort of thing
same thing with you know think about
neuroscience this incredible burgeoning
all sorts of fields neuroscience is
going to transform this neuroscience
tells us about that morality dating you
know business education everybody's got
to talk about neuroscience and they
produce these great you know scans of
the brain now can you do brain scans all
the time
as it turns out no you can only do them
under extremely narrow circumstances
people gotta sit still you got to do the
imaging now the imaging that we can do
is really quite cool and so within those
very particular niche experience ranges
we can actually learn quite a bit I mean
now you've gotten to the point where you
can like map out not just you know like
big portions of the brain and whether
they're lighting up or not lighting up
you can actually see what's connected to
what so but is that widespread no that's
really just the province of a few
individuals these are what we call
nascent sciences and they may in fact
turn out to measure up to the high
that they they bring about or they may
not actually turn out to be that way
they may turn out to be the you know the
new phrenology you know the history of
that pseudo discipline we have to wait
and see it has to become articulate it
has to no longer be the province of a
few individuals it has to be no longer
esoteric Hegel says that only what is
completely determined is at once s
exoteric comprehensible capable being
apprehended that's what science tends
towards it's open it's manifest it can
be learned by by all at least in theory
and perhaps not actually in practice you
know in our own society have to tear
people away from Netflix and you know
other things that are occupying them on
the internet and whatever other
occupations they have in order to get
them to do that but in theory a lot of
things could be learned by anybody who
wants to apply themselves to it and
that's what science tends towards so he
says the intelligible form of science is
the way open and equally accessible to
everyone so this is a very democratic
very egalitarian concept of science it's
not actually lowering science to you
know the lowest common denominator
saying well you got to make it so simple
that that even somebody who doesn't do
any cultivation any mental work can can
get it because that's not going to work
I mean we're talking about sophisticated
systematic conceptions of reality here
that do requires some development of the
person but they should be able to be
available to everybody
so he says consciousness as an approach
is science justly demands that it be
able to attain to rational knowledge by
way of the ordinary understanding by way
of the you know and franchised
ordinary understanding the disencumber
ordinary understanding for the
understanding is thought the pure I is
such and so it should be able to take it
in and make sense of it the new world
that we're beginning with in this this
passage is not yet at that point and
taking on the determinacy that the old
world had with form and content that's
going to be an integral part of the
development of of science of philosophy
as scientific
science in its early stages when it is
attained neither its completeness of
detail nor perfection of form is
vulnerable to criticism but it would be
just as unjust for criticism to strike
at the very heart of science as it is
untenable to refuse to honor the demand
for its further development this
polarization seems to be the Gordian
knot which which with which scientific
culture is at present struggling and
which it does not properly understand
one side boasts of its wealth of
material and intelligibility the other
side at least scorns us intelligibility
and flaunts its immediate rationality
and divinity even if the former side is
reduced to silence whether by the force
of truth alone in the blustering of the
other and even if in respect of
fundamentals it feels itself out matched
it is by no means satisfied regarding
the said demands for they are justified
but not fulfilled in its silence stems
only half from the triumph of its
opponent and half from the boredom and
indifference which tends to result from
the continual awakening of expectations
through unfulfilled promises
and this paragraph is
we've got a kind of two-step going on
where the first part of the paragraph is
setting out it can problematic and then
the second part is bringing out some
other aspects of that very problematic
in this case it's going to Center on
what Hegel calls the Gordian knot and
I'll tell you about that in just a
moment first I want to look at what he's
actually saying at the beginning so he
says that science early on science as
it's not fully developed it is
vulnerable to what to criticism to
somebody dismissing it to somebody
saying well you're not truly scientific
or you don't really grasp reality as
such there's things you're missing to
dismissal altogether this is not the way
to go and Hegel says that that's unfair
why is that unfair well because science
by its very nature and what is meaning
about science remember is not just what
we tend to think of as the scientists
and the labs and Stephen Hawking and
people like that what he means nor is it
just the popularization is a science you
know the people who do the sage on the
stage thing and do TED talks what he
means is this process of trying to
develop rigorous systematic knowledge
that can actually take account of itself
and that can make sense out of the
historical process by which it developed
it's a big undertaking so science is not
complete he says it's not completely in
its details that's that has to do with
content that means that for any given
point in time there's more that it has
to take in and you know you can think
about this there's there's even the
sciences that have been around for quite
a while like say biology they're still
discovering new species as a matter of
fact newer Sciences like the branch that
studies viruses just recently discovered
these large viruses that operate in a
somewhat different way and
that happens when they discover these
they're like oh I think we got to do
some rethinking of the very nature of
our our activity of them what it is that
we're studying so sometimes finding new
content isn't just a matter of filling
in gaps that you had it actually says
well I think there might be more gaps
out there we're not even really quite
sure where the the gaps are and that
leads us to the second part science is
not perfect in its form in what we are
calling articulation remember science in
order to really be science it has to
articulate the content that it has in a
way that actually does just as to what
it is that it's attempting to study and
its own self as the one who's studying
it that's a big order so science is
going to be continually developing this
is the natural course it's not a process
that you know you just finish up right
away and it's not a process that comes
up with its own scientific method which
then it applies cookie-cutter style to
everything that's out there that's
actually bad science scientific method
has had to be reconciled that means that
it has to become adequate to the things
that it's studying even if those seem to
be non-scientific efforts that means the
science has to stretch to use a term
that Hegel's not using so Hegel says
science needs further development it
requires them and so to criticize it on
that basis is a little bit unfair
because that would be sort of like
saying the a child who is not yet an
adult is therefore wrong for not being
an adult know it's part of the natural
process is the further development that
has to take place and
that development that often gets left
out is that science has to develop an
adequate understanding of what it is
doing its self what it's about what it's
about not in the sense of the subject
matter but what it's about in the sense
of what is it actually engaged in and
how does it do that
so he talks about this as bringing about
a polarization which is the Gordian knot
with which scientific culture is at
present struggling and which does not
yet properly understand so Hegel is
going to help us now to understand for
the science of his own time and perhaps
the supplies to to our understanding in
our own time what this Gordian knot is
so while I do a little bit of a race
sure and writing things up here let me
tell you the story of the Gordian dogs
when you use that expression it refers
to this really intricate knot that was
that was I don't know what it was made
of I'm assuming yarn because that was
that was a common thing at the time and
this was in ancient Greece and the story
of the Gordian knot concerns Alexander
the Great so Alexander the Great is
supposed to have run across this knot
and you know to be able to untie that
would actually be quite a feat not only
of patience but of wisdom and nobody had
been able to do it so how does Alexander
untie it it gets a sword and slices it
in half that's thinking outside the box
in a certain way isn't it because you're
actually you are untying the knot but
you're not in time to that in the sense
that you were supposed to and so Gordian
knot is sort of a byword or a puzzle
that that is really difficult to to
solve perhaps impossible to solve in
which you might solve only by producing
some sort of split some sort of
bifurcation and you talks about this as
a polarization
that scientific cultures fallen into so
you've got two sides you've got the the
one and the other just so we can stick
to the terminology use here so the one
side boasts of its wealth of material
and its intelligibility it means
everything is able to be understood and
the other side boasts of immediate
rationality so what have we got going on
here we've got a lot of content and
Locke form and then we've got the ones
who think that they're getting to the
real heart of the matter we've seen this
already with the appeal to intuition the
appeal to intuition can take the form of
the beautiful the true God religion
transcendentalism this this notion that
look you know you can jangle around all
you want with concepts and appearances
and discursive knowledge we're
penetrating to the heart of the matter
in a way that you can't possibly do nor
can you even understand you
stick-in-the-mud empiricists over here
or a rationalist by the way this is
something quite different and so these
two sides are kind of fighting with each
other you know and it makes sense
because you can pile up a lot of data a
lot of information and you can even
organize it and curate it but you can
still ask the question what the hell is
the point what are you actually getting
at what is this really about and that
sometimes seems to require some sort of
getting things as a whole these guys are
focusing on the whole the totality but
unfortunately they're reducing it to
something
you know soup what we see what we've
seen is not really deep but superficial
something that's in many respects
arbitrary these guys are going about the
you know workman like process of putting
things together but they're losing sight
of as we say the forest for the trees
these guys are all forest these guys are
all trees and he says that this side
over here at least in this paragraph
even if this side is reduced to silence
whether by the force of truth alone or
the blustering of the other because
people over here do bluster quite a bit
and even if for the respective
fundamentals that feels itself match
it's by no means satisfied regarding the
demands for the demands that science is
imposing this Gordian you know it's
Gordian knot of science the things make
sense that things be systematized that
things be put into a hole that can not
only you know contain everything be
completely exhaustive be comprehensive
but it actually makes sense of itself in
a reflexive way these guys are claiming
hey we're doing that and you aren't
these guys are saying you know I can see
that that's important but you guys
aren't really doing that you are making
a claim that is I want to use these
these exact terms again these demands
are justified but not fulfilled it's one
thing to say that you're gonna do
something or that the project that
you're working on is really an important
project and that can be true it's a
whole nother thing to make good on it
and these two sides are left with this
split in a kind of sisian he also talks
about the silence of this site stemming
from the boredom and indifference which
tend to result from the continual
awakening of expectations through
unfulfilled promises and again over here
you might think about this
as you know big-picture meaning though
the people that are the ideas man or
women who are going to put everything
into perspective
they they come out with some sort of
here's the idea you gotta get you know
and again we could say mindfulness and a
decade from now nobody's going to be
talking about mindfulness anymore and
it'll be some other trendy thing that's
on the scene and you know the
mindfulness thing will be just one more
branch of the study over here the
problem is these guys never make good it
sounds really cool it sounds like yeah
this is gonna revolutionize things this
is gonna help me get everything into
perspective but the problem is you're
good at fitting things into perspective
the one who can actually articulate
things the one who actually has some
sort of schema some sort of arrangement
some sort of what Hegel's calling form